The lower limit of this inequality is 5, but we can see that it's not included
in the interval, so we need a round parenthesis. We said that there is no
maximum value that x could take on. That means that the possible values of x
could extend to infinity. And, whenever we have infinity in an interval, we need
to use a round parenthesis. Infinity isn't a number that we can have a hard stop
at. It can't be included in an interval, because it's bigger than anything we
can quantify. So, we have to use a round parenthesis. If you had trouble getting
this, no big deal. I know this is a pretty new concept and definitely a new
notation with the infinity and how to use it with parenthesis. But, now you
know.